[Applaudissements]
dans les émissions pour être sûr de rien
louper et franchement je suis passée
inaperçue un peu comme en boîte
finalement c'est gwenaëlle qui choisit
voyelles et consonnes concerne
cette lettre fait andré huit lettres
avec jets bleuté oui ouais je suis pas
contente parce que ça va être mon regard
dépassement l'émission
[Musique]
à avoir encore beaucoup d'actualité bon
d'accueillir tout de suite notre invité
que l'on surnomme dans le football la
pleureuse
je vous demande d'accueillir à camille
ligne au combat l'espace
[Applaudissements]
bon forcément
bien ça a très bien accueillis nous a
éloigné des terrains pendant six saisons
et vous rejoignez à 43 ans aujourd'hui
le real madrid
avec ce transfert record de 25 euros
c'est vrai que c est un transfert énorme
comment vas tu es supporter une telle
pression et je crois que le plus
important c'est de faire des bonnes
prestations individuelles qui servent le
collectif que l'équipe s'y retrouve
il a à coeur de prendre les trois
coureurs dès le premier match alors
qu'elle en juillet aux babouches de
ouarzazate vos stats étaient là 22 tirs
0 buts zéro tir cadré 0 passe décisive
avec des performances pareil évidemment
l'équipe de france vous y pensez bien
sûr quand on fait de bonnes prestations
individuelles c'est vrai qu'on pense
forcément bleus prennent important au
delà des performances individuelles
c'est que le groupe se sente bien s'y
retrouve on a à coeur de prendre les
trois points et on espère fonder notre
les matchs sont impressionnants
entourage en tout cas de votre nouvelle
aventure nord dans cette équipe on passe
tout à la grande surface
nous avons pris un ensemble consisté à
permettre aux hôpitaux d'accéder à un
fonds interministériels de la
délinquance pour s'équiper en matière de
vidéoprotection
[Applaudissements]